for dramatic purposes patients in this
ship's infirmary are placed head-to-head
giving us the yin yang neo Smith shot we
didn't know we wanted I bring word from
the Oracle
you must come with ones I won't tell you
where though even though that's crucial
information we assume you can figure it
out for yourself
only this girl and her parents at the
terminal yet they ignore or enough so
that she can just start chatting up neo
and stuff this isn't the matrix that's
where the train goes thankfully she's
full of exposition oh look they knew
where to meet Seraph without him saying
anything about location wowie once in
for regular old mortality for causing
this franchise to have to recast a role
that was already perfectly cast do you
know what happened to neo yes he is
trapped in a place between this world
and the machine world
mystery man is cool and all but the
movie never even once tries to explain
how neo controlling the Sentinels in the
real world caused him to end up in this
train limbo he is placed a bounty on
your lives you must be careful at all
times because prior to this moment you
did not need to be careful sati come
here darling
leave the poor man in peace you've
coughed up enough exposition on him for
one day
I am sorry she is still very curious if
you were really sorry you'd have stopped
her from bothering me long before this
also he's a goddamn program out of
computer programs get so emotional and
irrational I just have never heard a
program speak of love it is a human
emotion no it is a word but Matt is is
the connection the word implies clever
dialogue but you're still suggesting
machines have emotions which is not only
weird but goes against what this series
of films has spent a lot of time trying
to prove I see that you are in love
computer program in another region place
can see Neos love for Trinity just by
looking at him this motherfucker is not
running fast enough to outrun the Oracle
let alone Seraph Trinity and Morpheus
also in the last cut at the turnstiles
this dude was nowhere near this far
ahead of them
guy who runs super slow only needs a
three-car subway going by to disappear
like vapour also even if that Head Start
is somehow a good one which it isn't
these assholes still just give up boy
that is that comma you believe in karma
dialogue like this really when you boil
it all down is why both matrix equals
end up being more boring than
entertaining so my big dead-ass soapy
classic case of a bad guy waiting too
damn long that just do what he was
threatening to do even with the element
of surprise serif and gang only managed
to kill one of the five gun check dudes
on the first spray but whatever slow
motion guns and rape music party time am
i right just a reminder no one in the
actual club which has the coat and gun
check just outside can hear this
I know clubs be loud but damn jesus this
room is a coat and gun check room it is
only this large with huge concrete
columns everywhere so that this accent
sequence can take place discount rave
scene from either of the two previous
matrixes or is it matrices oh who cares
I get why they're all three back-to-back
going through the dance floor but why do
they have to be constantly spinning
wouldn't staying in relative stationary
direction give each of the three a
better longer look at the surroundings
near them as opposed to constantly
spinning and scanning deejay wearing
headphones at a loud-ass club that
couldn't hear gunfire in the next room
somehow here's the Merovingian yelling
at him also gas attack victim DJ also
DJ's does every person at this bondage
nightclub know and respect the
Merovingian enough to be basically
soldiers for him I mean not one of them
is going to complain about why the music
stopped
none of these club goers drinking and/or
drunk I couldn't even tell you the owner
of my favorite nightclub if he walked up
to me in a spandex bodysuit and pinched
my ass or is this just the Merovingians
work headquarters and all these people
are henchmen and the dancing is just a
byproduct of having so many latex Laden
hadees all together in one room I am
curious though as to how it actually
happened yeah you and me both buddy
unfortunately the movie ain't got no
conclu itself how that should happen so
you'll just have to get over it move on
Trinity starts kicking ass and none of
the gun-toting henchmen do anything
allowing Morpheus and serve to also
start kicking ass without any good guys
getting shot despite all logic and
reason this chick down here does not
shoot Trinity the entire time she
watches and catches the gun I can't help
wonder how many other gun-toting
assholes are just off screen also not
shooting Trinity
latex bondage club Mexican standoff she
do it if she has so she kill every one
of us she's in love
thank God the third movie finally paid
off that completely weird and
emotionless true love's kiss in the
bathroom scene from the last movie I
can't I have to see her no no at some
later point in time
what the hell Trinity you get to see the
Oracle but your boyfriend who is the one
can't I was hoping to have these ten
before you got here
well you are the Oracle right couldn't
you just started making the dough a few
minutes earlier
since you've knew when he was coming I
think it's time for a tasty takes a bowl
to serve and find out if they're ready
Salmonella if you rearrange the letters
on the fridge it spells you wasted a
bunch of time looking at fridge letters
for humorous anagrams and came up empty
you are all that stands in his way
Smith man the Oracles the master of the
pronoun game she wrote the book on that
what is he he is you your opposite your
negative to be so took the equation
trying to balance itself out okay fair
enough but neo is the sixth one and we
already saw Smith himself say in the
last movie that his newfound power was a
new development in the repeating matrix
cycle and he said that way before neo
broke the cycle by saving Trinity
instead of Zion so what I'm saying is
you're foolish lady any time okay this
is one of the movie's biggest problems
to serve the story and the ebb and flow
of the action in the film neo spends a
super long time just thinking about what
he should do even though the Oracle just
told him in the last scene he already
knew what he needed to do if we weren't
trying to line up parallel crescendos
then neo would immediately head for the
machine city right now and end the war
before Zion gets attacked Agent Smith
somehow controls this building's power
okay fine but why is he shutting off the
lights one at a time for drama
Agent Smith is addictive cookies why did
you do that cert cookies need love like
everything does you are past well you're
the one that had city alone with you in
an abandoned building when you're new
Smith was coming
so here's neon still seeing visions of
the police he already knows he needs to
go still not going these grids are
sneaky bastards could be a trap but
wouldn't you pick them up on your
scanners haven't we seen multiple times
already that you can do that also
discount inside the space monsters
throat scene from Empire Strikes Back
what did you tell you the same thing she
always does exactly what I needed to
hear
oh that's useful Thanks overhead shot of
supposedly small a Saiyans suggest there
are millions more inhabitants that
originally believed movie repeats Matrix
Reloaded it's mistake of thinking we
give a shit about these two going on
over here what the pod born pencil-neck
like you doing volunteering for Michael
that's racist and do the Zion born
people Harbor some kind of
discrimination or ill-will against
people born in the pod farm if so why
isn't that flushed out a little bit more
I can't even see it the stages in Zion
those are the ones with Bloods on their
mugs movie repeats Matrix Reloaded it's
mistake of thinking me give it a chance
I won't let you down
again I mean I'm sorry that I took so
long so are we we leave inside the ow we
should reach Zion as the machines do
imagine when you could have arrived if
neo hadn't taken his sweet-ass time on
this decision this guy's been playing
his part correct the entire time for
days but now he decides to monologue and
basically warn this chick about his
evilness before killing her how the
Trinity and you actually lose chemistry
as a couple as these movies go along how
was that possible it's not like they had
a ton to begin with did Lucas guest
direct these scenes I ain't saying
goodbye I'm not saying goodbye cliche
she survives this miss turns this phrase
alone does not immediately cause Agent
Smith light bulbs for neo and Trinity
and that's some bull now I know this is
Agent Smith we're talking about here and
his ego is nearly as big as Sean Penn's
but still sinning for the bad guy
wasting time and not killing him already
thankfully the shards from that light
she smashed on Baines head a few minutes
ago her handy to help her cut her binds
I realize she's probably limited in what
she can do to help but doesn't turning
out the lights limit your boyfriend as
much as it does the enemy
sigh Messiah man trilogy that doesn't
want you to miss that Jesus parallels
really doesn't want you to miss the
Jesus parallels even now that he's
blinded neo Smith still feels the need
to mess with him instead of just
punching him in the ear and then kill
him with the gun
movie also never explains how neo was
the first and only of all the ones that
could see in control machines outside
the actual matrix but whatever cool shot
I guess thought I think it can ask the
tribe I can't he drive the ship when he
can sense and feel everything now this
what in tarnation are these screens
behind locks supposed to be showing and
how is this information in this
graphical display any kind of useful
movie rips off the robot mech suits from
the Matrix Reloaded this is it movie
shows us a vast shot of AP us then shows
us their commander giving the pre-war
speech in a speaking voice the third row
is probably struggling to hear if it's
our time to die it's our time well
that's inspiring robot roll call
alright so do that so you can scan for
sentinels what was that worried again
earlier when you thought they might be
ambushing you they're inching along
trying to sneak up on millions of
sentinels but everyone is in the cockpit
probably so that they have to scramble
and waste time Manning the guns when
they made a stupid noise to alert the
sentinels to their presence knew it
Systema Gunter's yeah late much blatant
Star Wars homage is Star Wars the proper
piloting of this hovercraft will require
the removal of my sweater the stone
concrete ceiling is capable being
pierced without the whole thing raining
down on bitches and we've known for ages
what direction these assholes were
coming from but sure yeah let's wait
until the last second to train our guns
on the spot knuckle up machine drillers
are basically self reviving transformers
machines wait forever to send the full
strength of Sentinel forces then the
Sentinels join 5 streams into one for
the main assault making themselves much
easier to target for the few guns that
exist in the stock the centrioles are
terrible at finding humans until the
humans shoot rockets at them
how is a giant-ass hover ship faster
than these motherfuckers the Sentinels
blow off a hover pad in two seconds flat
but how much you want to bet it ticks
him forever to get the rest of them all
we can hack into the matrix and put
humans inside a computer program wearing
and carrying anything we want but when
it comes to targeting computers just
triangles dog that's all we can offer
sorry oh damn these how to craft are
built like in tanks can you see that
little aerial Stoffel you haven't even
tried to use the radio to call Zion once
why protect what you're not using also
call Zion on the radio before the radio
gets destroyed goddamn it the Sentinels
are terrible at finding humans until the
human shoot rockets at them either these
sentence have the aim of stormtroopers
or else these gals are luckier than
Andrew Luck on a luck dragon
no one can pilot you ten I bet there's
at least one person who can and I bet
the movie tells us how awesome a pilot
that person is about 153 times we blow
any appeals either will lose the duck
sir we already lost the dog
open the gate how in the fuck are you
giving the Morpheus later about blowing
the EMP when you went out of your way to
help him do it before they finalized
character names for the script this
dude's name red is 100% dick guy number
one relatively random carnage has ironic
timing dear welcome you can drop we
ain't home yet how did you hear that you
don't have a headset on anymore are all
his comments just broadcast shipwide
this guy wouldn't be alive anymore of
entire swarms of sentinels weren't
constantly passing him by there are
clearly more than enough sentinels here
to keep this guy from making an ammo run
let alone eventually saving the day and
while we're at it how come the
super-strong EXO soup things can only
carry two boxes of ammo at a time that's
a design flaw I've ever seen one cool
shot I guess but what the hell are these
sentinels doing showing off is it like a
machine version of ribbon ballet
gymnastics or something so what I don't
do anything to you when they fly past
you anyway what's the worry none of the
10000 sentinels swarming and eating and
killing buffoon II noticed the delicious
teenage human dangling off the back
maybe they read the script
la campagne finish the training program
movie repeats Matrix Reloaded mistake of
thinking but you did finish the dying
with one eye open program that's the
main Zack charge me yeah cuz that's not
something you could have done earlier or
anything yeah you believe what but there
is no spoon shooting this thing will
open the door that Nia was the one you
already believed that didn't you why are
you wasting time to say this thing also
I guarantee neo does not give a shit
about whether or not you believe you
know even if they survive this machine
attack everyone in Sion is gonna die of
smoke inhalation anyway you're miles
underground after an EMP where's all
this light coming from right now
you're a hell of a pilot after telling
us for two movies that Niobe is a hell
of a pilot and then actually showing us
die OB in the act of being a hell of a
pilot repetitive movie feels compelled
yet again to tell you she's a hell of a
pilot thank God the stock is on fire
right now I'm alright or else none of us
would be able to see you in order to
cheer you did I miss something commander
I felt we just saved the dog that's the
problem with you people
you can't think but five minutes in
front of their face you when the woman
who ordered the dock door open so they
could do the thing they did that you're
now being a dick about dick that EMP
knocked out almost every piece of
hardware in every APU why only almost
every piece of hardware it knocked out
every Sentinel even the ones outside the
dock already escaping but the good guys
still have some equipment left that
works save the dock captain just handed
it to him on a silver platter well you
did but whatever semantics I suppose I
guess we're using those minimally
lasting damage
EMPs where everything can be restarted
instantly except the dead sentinels of
course cuz he's the one who believes in
miracles meanwhile back at the 3d
electrical conduits also why did the
machines build the fields of humans so
far away from the machine city was it
just for dramatic timing purposes
yes wait one did the Sentinel ghost come
through the ship but not its physical
body are they currently fighting against
both physical and ghosts sentenced go up
over the sky but we're in a hovercraft
Neil there's a limit to how far we can
hover from things like earth premature
self-congratulations
which I will do here in a moment
provided I don't run out of breath and
die during this setup just say it
already
gasp crying oh sure it takes him six
hours to think about whether or not he's
sure about his mission but morning
Trinity that's over in seconds the blind
neo can see light thing is cool for sure
but this makes it look like he's got no
idea if he's stepping on solid surfaces
or about to plunge to his death literal
deus ex machina also were the machines
like we'd better at least appear human
when we negotiate with this human
because that way he won't realize we're
machines
he's sentinels land and then instead of
attacking they just stop forward then
the humans respond by not attacking this
is a weird-ass battle the machines just
accept this thunder and lightning
indicate the matrix of ganda how do all
the identical agent Smith's know which
one of them is the true original one
that gets to fight neo and while we're
on that subject what was the point in
making all the Agent Smith clones if you
were still gonna fight neo with just one
of them
I realize Smith winning is exactly how
do wins but Smith doesn't know that he
should be attacking neo with all the
Smiths it ends tonight I know it does
I've seen it that's why the rest of me
is just gonna win enjoy the show
a couple problems here first off how is
Smith getting visions now didn't Neal
get visions previously too in this very
movie I know they're yin and yang and
all that but I would Smith gain visions
and Neill lose them why didn't you have
any visions of this event second are you
actually telling me cockiness is the
reason Smith chooses to fight neo is one
man instead of an army of millions
because I'm pretty sure the real reason
is special effects cost kung-fu flux of
defiance this is the second huge
exploding slow-motion ball of water shot
in the last three minutes it's cool
effect and all but the movie will show
us Neos revelation about how he needs to
die to kill Smith here in a few moments
so my question is what's his plan right
now fight to the death with each of the
millions of agent Smith's one at a time
this movie is more in love with it
slow-motion exploding water effects than
it is with a story or any of its
characters Superman is a dictum of drop
oh wait yeah no need to fly to the
location of impact walking dramatically
will suffice
also production saved a ton of money on
rain machine rental and green camera
filters by shooting on the road to
perdition set I believe you're fighting
for something more than your survival
and you tell me what it is do you even
know yeah um he's fighting to end the
machine war with humans he's actually
come here prepared to die honestly
you're the most in the dark character in
the film right now only a human mind
could invent something is it separate us
love but the program dude back at the
train station went to great lengths to
waste lots of my time by explaining the
machines to feel low so now I'm confused
plastic punch he saved us the military
commanders aren't even positive the
Sentinels are leaving for real and for
good but sure KITT go run and tell all
of Zion that the war was over without
any actual proof all you know is that
this current battle is paused and may be
over why is the Chancellor hanging out
15 yards behind the frontlines
oh sure when the sent alarm II was
approaching you held a sweaty naked
dance party in here but now that the war
is over it's just hugs
I demand quick flashes of interracial
nudity reluctant peacekeeping machines
show respect to Neos dead body instead
of just logically turning it immediately
into liquid fuel a happy word what do
you think I am human right because the
machines haven't ever lied or been
deceitful this entire series
that's why the rest of me is just going
to enjoy the show
if you're looking for a berserk night
out in in the new New York I know just
the place for you new New York's hottest
club is whimsy condemned by glad and the
EPA from ghostbusters this old wet
band-aid found in a ditch in a jacuzzi
is the kind of place that makes you feel
weird the next time you see your parents
my eyes the dogwoods do nothing
spawn tags what is your profession
say what's the need to say
comrades our own fleet doesn't know our
full potential we will do everything
possible to test us but they will only
test their own embarrassment we will
pass through the American patrols past
their Sona nets and lay off their larger
city and listen to their rock and roll
while we conduct missile drill I'm gonna
be your best friend good feelings gone